being a good men user is much like a
good marriage a constant balancing act
requiring a large aura investment and a
perpetual fear of the abilities of your
spouse
opponent but then again when it comes to
nen just being good
isn't quite good enough no we need to
find the best
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are going to embark
on some sort of grand journey to
discover the 20 best nin users in hunter
hunter not at all an easy thing to
discover actually due to the highly
subjective and situational nature of
nenus so instead of doing my regular
thing and just you know stating a blunt
opinion i've actually constructed a very
special methodology to discover our nen
champions a process that involved me
analyzing 119 nan wielders within hunter
hunter and quite frankly it took me a
pretty disgusting amount of time to
complete so please do justify my life
choices by subscribing to the new world
review which will also result in regular
hunt onto content being uploaded
straight into your youtube feeds now i
understand that not everyone is going to
be interested in the methodology and if
you do want to get straight into the
list then you can simply skip to this
time
however i would encourage you to stay
because it's very important to
understand our ranking criteria and if
you do get bored then we'll have a
slideshow of hunter hunter ladies
playing in the bottom corner here just
to keep your attention so you keep your
eyes there whilst the adults talk
essentially though every nen user was
ranked according to four categories in
each of these four the user was assigned
a score out of 25 and then the four
categories were added together to
achieve a final score out of 100. the
first category being aura this is
designed to measure the sheer quantity
of aura that an end user has access to
and this is obviously important because
the more aura one has the more fuel they
have for nin use and the scale i've used
for this comes courtesy of knuckle who
measured gone moral and up giving us
quantifiable aura units however with
that said most nen users in hunt hunt
would actually rank below gone in terms
for a quantity so i used him as
something of a halfway mark for measure
very very few people have been able to
reach morals or a quantity and even less
so youpis the next section though
is efficiency which aims to measure how
effectively a user implements their aura
because just having a lot of the aura is
great but if you're not using it
efficiently then it's just a complete
waste and in contrast there are also a
lot of nen users in the series who have
minuscule quantities of aura such as
komagi but they use what little they
have
wildly efficiently so it's a pretty
important category meanwhile our third
criteria is versatility and through this
i aim to quantify how well a nen user
can adapt their abilities to any given
situation and the other famous example
here would be moral who possesses the
infinitely versatile deep purple which
will go on to serve him well in any
given scenario meanwhile someone like
neil nastrad with her lovely ghost rider
ability has almost no versatility
because it's a very bizarre niche power
and our final category is
mastery the idea behind this is to
measure experience knowledge and depth
of menus and examples of super solid
nine mastery would be pretty much any
graduate of the shingen ryu school of
kung fu because they are taught to
harness the most advanced principles of
nen on the other hand someone who is
still
in the process of learning these
principles like seizure would not
achieve a particularly great score and
with all of that said there were also a
couple of rare instances where nen users
were awarded bonus points for
transcending certain aspects of nenu's
i'd give you an example of what that is
but that would mean spoiling the list so
just keep an eye out for it and so we
are going to hop
into this beast of a list commencing
with the 20th best nen user in hunt
hunter
the ant king marowam and i can't help
but feel like i've already caused some
kind of controversy however i would hope
by this point that we all understand
that being the strongest does not
automatically equal being the best
especially without criteria mirom is
obviously perfect in aura because well
he has more than any other character who
has ever been showcased in hunt hunter
but where he begins to stumble is
efficiency and versatility for all of
his godly aura quantity marowan never
really needed to push the bounds of
innovation
nor did he ever need to worry about
trivial concepts such as efficient use
which is very much a curse of having so
much aura i suppose and while i cannot
deny that meruem is an incomparable
genius he does also lose a lot of value
in mastery once again because he never
really explored nen in any sense of
depth which just goes to show that as
monstrous as marijuana was there was
still
limitless room for improvement which is
pretty terrifying and had he been alive
for more than
say 40 days i'm sure that he probably
would have topped this list however we
can only work with what we have and so
the ant king will need to settle for
20th moving on though we find ourselves
with feitan porter in 19th place
trumping the ant king by a mere half
point
and that is made up for in mastery
feitan is of course an end veteran who
has a much greater grasp and knowledge
base of the art form i do want to say
that feitan also scored very highly in
aura because his core ability does have
a mechanism of transmuting pain into
aura an awful lot of
aura which allows him to surpass most
users in the series it's also heavily
implied that his ability is part of a
series granting great versatility as
does his swiss army knife usage of the
common principles of nen
all in all feitan is just a solid
behemoth of an end user wrapped in the
package of a sadistic
pint-sized lad but keeping things within
the phantom troop for now one member who
does outrank phaeton on this occasion
would be bernoullinov
the first huge surprise for me on this
list actually however it does check out
and where bernoullinov really
demonstrates his superiority is with
versatility and efficiency banalinov has
a series of nen abilities that range
from simple battle armor to morphing
into other people or even objects
and then there's the whole thing where
he conjures the planet
jupiter the latter of which is what
gives me the confidence to place his
aura score so high as well and after
examining him closely i feel like
bernoullinov is just
a shockingly underrated member of the
phantom troop but then marching forward
into number 17 we find ourselves face to
face
unfortunately with fourth prince
ceridnik which may seem quiet at odds
with the fact that canonically he's only
been an
end user for a couple of weeks at this
stage however ceradnit comes with a huge
x-factor which is that he is a genius
unlike any we've seen before to put it
into some perspective if gone and
kilauea are said to have a 1 in 10
million talent for n then seradnik would
have a one in a billion talent
everything just comes to him so
ridiculously easily and if anything he
is simply loved by aura to the point
where he just subconsciously wields nen
in an efficient versatile and masterful
manner be it conjuring a fearsome nun
beast or developing an ability to see
into the future like meroem saratnik is
a grand exception to the general rules
of nenus however unlike miroem saradnik
actually plans on wielding then to its
fullest extent
which is a deeply despairful thought so
some very dark times ahead in hunter
hunter in 16th place however we discover
one
silver zoldick someone who i'll be
honest very much makes his way onto this
list through clout alone because there
were times when i was examining nen
users that i really just had to make
reasonable assumptions and with silver
those assumptions came in the areas of
mastery and efficiency there is
absolutely no way that as the head of
the zelda council silva has
anything less than a supreme mastery and
as a professional assassin he will
almost certainly have incredible
efficiency as well his profession just
demands both of these things
meanwhile his aura has been on full
display on one occasion and it is big
very big but i will say that his
versatility suffers simply because
we haven't seen quite enough of his
abilities as of yet and i don't have a
lot to base any reasonable assumptions
on
so silva you be here as for someone we
do have extensive knowledge on in comes
razer
at number 15. this man is pure insanity
he is often credited as being one of the
most powerful and versatile through what
we saw of him on greed island however
when you stop to think about exactly how
greed island even exists then you
realize that we need to give razer
even more credit razer's personal aura
is responsible for any and all emissive
effects of the cards on the island and
hizora is a large factor of what keeps
this game running and even with that
allocation to the game of greed island
he still has enough
left over to be the grand beast he is
razer is someone who at 100
could decimate the large majority of pro
hunters and i will always find it a bit
sad that he is destined to remain on
greed island for what seems to be the
rest of his days and as for another sad
story here's
nov a very powerful exploration of
trauma in series but also a pretty
stunning end user nov side and sikhatsu
encapsulates all four of these
categories to a very high degree firstly
the fact that he
on his own has enough aura to create an
entire pocket dimension the size of a
grand mansion
is absurd and it also speaks to how
efficiently he can use his aura to make
this even possible and through this
ability he has a ridiculous degree of
versatility and options for use plus he
is also a demonstrable master of men
with a theoretical knowledge on par with
the highest ranking hunters of the
association and to put it quite simply
nov is a boss a nen boss to number 13
now we have the delightful biscuit who
you will notice as the first character
to have been awarded some elusive bonus
points hmm
and that's because biski has gone above
and beyond what should be
humanly possible with nenus by using raw
desire to access an ability to change
her body at will
and this may seem simple but the key
thing to remember is that this really
should not be possible other than
specialization none of the nine
affinities allow for this phenomenon to
occur
especially not biski's native
transmutation i mean there is a
potential explanation in an extreme form
of enhancement which is sort of backed
up by gon doing a similar thing with his
adult form but even if that is the case
biski only becomes that much more
impressive
because she accessed a similar
transformative effect without making a
deadline vow
even if it was to do the reverse it's
still very impressive
so biski well and truly deserves her
points as well as her placement here
today
and next up we have another teacher of
gone and killua being mr kite or i
should probably say
miss kite these days but kite is kind of
like a poster boy for efficiency and
versatility the crazy slots ability
provides kite with a variety of tools
that are capable of handling most given
situations
and they are also used extremely
efficiently by placing a series of
restrictions upon said usage
one being that kite is unable to select
the weapon used but even after that some
of the randomized weapons even come with
restrictions of their own thus
multiplying kite's effectiveness by the
mathematical terminology of
lots kite is quite simply one of the
best a truly enviable mind in the realm
of nenus
and in stark stark contrast now we have
men
through the up in 11th place someone who
gets by with
let's say less mental effort however
when you are a royal guard
does that even matter and the answer is
maybe but up scores a perfect
25 for aura as will all of the royal
guard because their quantities
may as well be endless up also does
surprisingly well in versatility though
because he can morph himself to respond
to pretty much any given situation even
grow wings so despite the fact that he
began life as a rather basic
punch man style existence he did evolve
into something pretty damn great with
that said he definitely had room to
improve in efficiency though once again
that is the curse of boundless aura and
that's a very similar situation that we
have for our 10th place finisher
neferbito in fact
pito has the exact same stats as up
according to my criteria but
for a weirdly different reason in pito's
case they score high in versatility
because they are a specialist and were
thus capable of creating probably
any non-ability that they could have
dreamt of especially with the infinite
aura reservoir of royal guard like yupi
though pito loses points in efficiency
because there was very little thought
paid to that aspect
thinking of abilities like dr blyth this
was such a poorly thought out heart so
in retrospect and that's because pito
wasn't at all thinking of effective
menus when crafting it pito was just
thinking about having fun
and trying to revive kite so naturally a
far more frivolous ability was generated
as a result of that in all fairness
though pito does still score decently
because they did have some more refined
instances like the terps core ability
which was pretty great all around but
still pito is yet another victim
of not really being pressured to use
nenu's to its most effective degree now
in the opposite camp we find illumi
zoldick in 9th place someone who
certainly doesn't rival a royal guard in
terms for a quantity however a figure
who outclasses them in pretty much every
other area of nenu's and everything i
said about silva well very much applies
to illumi as well
just to a more demonstrable degree as a
trained assassin illimi is automatically
going to possess top tier mastery and
deficiency but where he triumphs over
silver is versatility because for a pure
manipulator illumi has
a disgustingly wild degree of different
ways to implement this incredibly basic
concept it doesn't matter what it is
anything illumi wants to be done can be
done whether by using his abilities or
by manipulating others and quite frankly
he puts other fantastic manipulators
like sharnak to shame and that's why
illumi is awarded with the coveted
number nine next up though we finally
encounter one of our main protagonists
of the series garoppolo who has landed
himself in eighth place
and you may immediately notice that
karapika's aura score is quite
comparatively low in fact i think it's
the lowest of this entire list and
that's because karapika doesn't come
close to rivaling anyone
in terms of raw aura but how he makes up
for that is by being a master of
efficiency and versatility karapika
takes what aura he has
and min maxes the hell out of it mostly
by emperor time which allowed him to
create and access a variety of abilities
that make use of his neighboring and
even weakness affinities plus it's also
hard to call the only nen user in the
series who can actively switch
affinities anything less than pretty
damn fantastic which may just be the
luck of the draw with the scarlet eyes
but
it is still there krapika is a very
scary blonde boy thing
not scarier than number seven though
where we find ourselves a familiar clown
magician hisoka and for someone who
exists for such a seemingly
flippant life purpose hisoka has really
given his all to pursuing nen for said
purpose
his aura quantity is undeniably large
but like karapika hisoka's deadliest
weapon comes with efficiency and
versatility hisoka can seemingly use
bungie gum to get himself out of most
situations and the simplicity of its
implementation is
almost mind-bogglingly awe-inspiring
especially compared to the weird complex
abilities of most of his contemporaries
and without going into spoilers hisoka
has only become a greater nan user in
every single aspect after a certain
event
hmm mysterious to number six though we
have our final
royal guard shirapoof who rather
surprisingly at least to me
has managed to significantly outrank the
other two surprising because at face
value i would almost always place pito
above pouf
mostly for the specialization aspect
however what pouf has going in his favor
that the other two simply do
not is raw efficiency hoof isn't the
kind of blunt head-to-head fighter that
the others are and he actually crafts
his abilities with great subtlety and
control
through stuff like the beelzebub hatsu
poof has a demonstrable insight into how
to dedicate these micro quantities vora
in order to achieve their greatest
possible effect
and in general he just thinks a lot more
than both pito and up whom rely more on
natural instincts and that is what has
ended up pushing pouf into sixth place
whilst the others were 10th and 11th
respectively still not quite top 5
material though but to commence our rise
to the pinnacle i will present you
with moral in 5th place a man with the
most versatile single nun ability we've
seen in the entire series
also someone with what should be a
staggering amount of aura only really
surpassed by the true monsters of nature
that hunter hunter has to offer but what
has always impressed me most about moral
is just efficiency moral is an extremely
rare individual whose primary hatsu
makes use of his most
unfriendly net ability being
transmutation however through a stupidly
clever system of restrictions and minor
reliance on the affinity
moral takes that and incorporates it
into his strengths to craft a glorious
aberration of the world and yeah it
takes someone pretty serious to surpass
moral and i would say we only have
about four of those we have four of
those in hunter hunter the first of
which
is xenozoldic dragon diving himself
straight into fourth place when the
words nen master are uttered the first
image in my head is usually of zeno his
experience
his profession his contacts his
abilities everything is designed for
xeno to succeed under the criteria that
i have laid out
and it's actually kind of difficult to
know what to say about zeno that isn't
just
like absolutely obvious from his feats
in the series his aura quantity is on a
completely different level to most he
has the efficiency of a master and
assassin he can adapt to any scenario
and he is one of the greatest
established nun masters in this entire
world
so i guess that's that well that's that
until we step into pure insanity where
we first discover
crolo lucifer in third place now he does
not have the aura quantity of someone
like cesino but for a man who can
acquire pretty much any other none
ability
it would be inaccurate to give krollo
anything less than a perfect score and
versatility what's more impressive
though is that skill hunter is an
ability that should be nigh on
impossible to implement the restrictions
are absolutely ridiculous however crollo
isn't mine sharp enough to take the
impossible and just make it work hence
the shockingly high scoring efficiency
chrollo exists on this supremely thin
line pushing the limits of men to their
extremes whilst of course knowing
exactly when
and where to compromise and what results
is this overwhelmingly marvelous nen
wielder a description that i would also
apply to our second place finisher jing
freaks now jing is someone that
i would often refuse to rank on a list
like this because i previously held the
opinion that we just did not have enough
information regarding him
and for reference that opinion does
still apply to characters like paristan
and actually most of the zodiacs we just
don't know anywhere near enough about
them so they did not rank very highly at
all if i bothered to rank them at all
however
jing is very different especially with
what we know in the manga
jing is a he's a completely different
type of nen user having demonstrated an
ability to copy the powers of other nan
users which i want to emphasize
is not jinx hatsu the fact is that jing
is just such a great nin user that he
can immediately dissect and copy the
abilities of others through technical
aura wielding and not only that he can
also use them to a far more effective
degree blast is someone who has been
quite literally referred to as one of
the top five best men users in the world
it's just not canonically feasible to
deny him a place on a list like this in
anything other than a top 5 spot but of
course the person who made that claim
about jing happens to be our number one
contender and the person who i solidly
believe
is the best end user in series isaac
natara although we do have a bit of
another bizarre situation happening here
in terms of aura efficiency
and mastery netro achieves obvious full
marks where he does lose a huge chunk of
points though
is versatility because having thoroughly
explored netero his abilities are geared
towards one aspect alone being combat
preferably 101 combat and using a giant
statue for that purpose
also doesn't help especially when you
need to resummon it every time you move
however netro is also the beneficiary of
elusive bonus points
because he has transcended his natural
human limits by spending
years and years training and meditating
in the mountains to the point where he
became a legitimate superhuman and that
acquired superhumanity plays a major
role in his menus allowing him to really
become the beacon of life that none can
surpass
and while netero would ultimately lose
to the number 20th spot on this list
maruem that has next to nothing to do
with actual menus
in fact the very idea that netro was
even capable of standing up to the ant
king
speaks more profoundly to his nan
mastery than any words that i could ever
hope to conjure and so as a result
mr netro will be crowned as the best men
user in hunter hunter and if you'd like
to see more fun
and shenanigan read then please do check
out this video of the most useful noun
abilities in the series lots of great
stuff in that so i look forward to
seeing you there